THEIR STORES.
VLAD?
>> MEG OLIVER, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
>>> INTERNATIONAL CALLS FOR A
CEASE-FIRE BETWEEN ISRAEL AND
HAMAS ARE GROWING.
VIOLENCE ERUPTED ACROSS THE WEST
BANK YESTERDAY AS HUNDREDS OF
PROTESTERS CLASHED WITH ISRAELI
TROOPS.
MORE THAN 215 PALESTINIANS HAVE
BEEN KILLED SINCE THE FIGHTING
STARTED MORE THAN A WEEK AGO.
ONE DOZEN PEOPLE ARE DEAD IN
ISRAEL.
HOLLY WILLIAMS REPORTS FROM TEL
AVIV.
>> Reporter: PALESTINIAN ANGER
EXPLODED ON TO THE STREET IN
RAMALLAH, BUT THE CLASHES AS
ALWAYS WERE UNEQUAL.
THE PALESTINIANS HAVE BEEN
THROWING STONES, AND THE ISRAELI
SOLDIERS WHO ARE ABOUT 300 YARDS
AWAY ON THAT HILLSIDE HAVE BEEN
SHOOTING TEARGAS CANISTERS AND
LIVE FIRE.
IT WAS MAINLY YOUNG MEN HURLING
ROCKS, BUT OTHER PROTESTERS WERE
MIDDLE-CLASS FAMILIES, CHILDREN
AND WHITE-COLLAR WORKERS.
PEOPLE LIKE MAISOON ALI.
>> THEIR LIVES IS NOT WORTH MORE
THAN OUR LIVES.
IT'S NOT WORTH MORE THAN OUR
KIDS.
>> Reporter: YOU'RE SAYING PEACE
TALKS DON'T WORK.
>> NO.
25 YEARS, WHAT DID IT GIVE US?
>> Reporter: FOUR PALESTINIANS
WERE REPORTED KILLED, AND ISRAEL
CLAIMS TWO SOLDIERS WERE SHOT IN
THE LEG, THOUGH WE SAW NO GUNS
ON THE PALESTINIAN SIDE.
PALESTINIAN US FRUSTRATION IS W
FUELS HAMAS, A GROUP CONSIDERED
A TERRORIST ORGANIZATION BY THE
U.S.
IT'S FIRED MORE THAN 3,000
ROCKETS AT ISRAEL SINCE LAST
WEEK, KILLING TWO CIVILIANS
YESTERDAY.
IN RETALIATION, THE TINY,
POVERTY-STRICKEN GAZA STRIP HAS
BEEN SHATTERED WITH BLISTERING
ISRAELI AIR STRIKES.
ISRAEL SAYS IT'S TARGETING
MILITANTS.
AND PRIME MINISTER BENJAMIN
NETANYAHU SAYS HIS COUNTRY'S
ENEMIES ARE LEARNING A LESSON.
SUZY ISHKONTANA IS JUST 7 YEARS
OLD.
SHE WAS PULLED FROM THE RUBBLE
AFTER AN ISRAELI STRIKE, LOSING
HER MOTHER AND FOUR SIBLINGS.
SOME OF THE MORE THAN 60
CHILDREN KILLED BY THE ISRAELI
BOMBARDMENT, ACCORDING TO
PALESTINIAN OFFICIALS.
HAMAS HAS TOLD CBS NEWS THAT ONE
OF ITS CONDITIONS FOR A
CEASE-FIRE IS THAT ISRAELI
SOLDIERS NEVER AGAIN SET FOOT IN
THE AL AQSA MOSQUE IN JERUSALEM.
THOSE WHO KNOW THIS PART OF THE
WORLD WILL TELL YOU THAT IS
HIGHLY UNLIKELY.
>> AND SO IT CONTINUES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH